Now let's discuss hash based
approach to message authentication.
Using hash values for message
authentication has several advantages.
For example, hash functions
are very efficient to compute.
And libraries of hash functions
are widely available.
On the other hand, a hash function such
as SHA cannot be used directly and
by itself for message authentication
because it does not rely on a secret.
There have been a number of proposals
to incorporate a secret key
into an existing hash function.
The approach that has received
the most support is HMAC, and
it has been adopted to other
protocols such as IPsec and TLS.
Here's an illustration
of how HMAC works.
HMAC invokes a hash function and
also secret key K.
The message M consists of
multiple blocks of b bits, for
example, for SHA 512.
Each block is 1,024 bits,
so b would be 1,024.
So the key K would be
first padded to b bits.
This is accomplished by simply
appending zeros to the end of K.
Then the padded key is XORed with ipad,
which is a constant designed to
eliminate any irregularities of the key.
And the result is a b bit S1.
S1 is prepended to the original message.
Then the entire message there is S1, and
the original message is hashed
to produce a n bit hash value.
For example, if the hash function
is SHA 512, then n will be 512.
Then the n bit hash value again
will be padded to b bits.
Then the padded key,
K+, is XORed with opad.
Again, opad is another constant designed
to eliminate irregularities in the key.
The result is a b bit value, S0.
The padded hash is then appended to S0,
and the entire message is hashed.
And the n bit result is HMAC of
the message with the key, K.
And this is how HMAC works.
To summarize,
HMAC uses an existing hash function and
includes a secret key,
K, in the processing.